over the weekend mark german's power on
newsletter gave us a huge amount of
clarity in terms of what's going to
happen with the imac later this year
he said that this year the transition to
apple silicon will shift into high gear
with several new mac models based on the
following processors a new m2 chip last
year's m1 pro and m1 max chips and new
super powered versions of the m1 max and
to give you some more context on what
those super power chips will be
apple is said to be taking multiple m1
max dies and combining them together
using a die to die interconnect in sets
of either two or four dies to
essentially create m1 max duo and m1 max
quadro super chips and that first m1 max
duo chip was exactly what we were
expecting to go into the imac pro for
various reasons which i'm gonna show and
explain in this video including internal
software leaks but unfortunately mark
german has just made it completely clear
that he doesn't believe the imac pro is
gonna be getting this new super powered
m1 max duo chip which is extremely
disappointing so before i explain
exactly what he said over this weekend
and why it's so important to understand
i want to first get into all the reasons
why we thought it made sense for the
imac pro to get this new high-powered
chip with both leaks and common sense so
let's get right into that last year in
november after we already got our hands
on the new m1 pro and m1 max macbook
pros ross young confirmed that the new
imac pro will be coming with a 27-inch
mini led display with 120hz pro motion
technology and that right there was a
big deal because it hinted to us that
apple was about to go all out on this
new imac pro since implementing that
technology would be pretty expensive and
then shortly after that a software
developer named hector martin who was
currently working on bringing linux to
apple silicon max found something
groundbreaking
in terms of these new m1 max dies
apparently the irq controller in the m1
max is very clearly engineered with a
currently unused second half for a
second die he even said it's technically
a second set of registers that are
currently all idle and going even
further the irq controller only has
support for up to two dies not four and
because of all this it basically showed
that apple had already put everything in
place in terms of the software side of
mac os to connect two m1 max dies but
not yet for four of them so this led me
to believe that apple planned to release
an m1 max duo mac before the release of
the next macos software version which
would mean that we should see a new m1
max duo imac pro in the spring before
apple announces the new mac os in june
like they always do but what really got
me believing in an m1 max duo imac pro
was a couple of very good points made by
some people on twitter first of all the
apple tree made a great point about the
limitations of the regular m1 max chip
specifically that it only supports up to
64 gigs of unified memory which is
already half the amount compared to
apple's current intel 27-inch imac from
2020. so if apple wanted to keep that
same 128 gig ram option around the best
way to do that would be to introduce the
m1 max duo chip with literally double
the number of ram chip slots and then
going further he pointed out that the m1
max 32 core gpu is limited to around
10.4 t flops of performance which is
definitely lacking compared to other
desktop gpus like for example only
matching up to the raw performance of
the rtx 2080 or the rx vega 56 which is
literally built into the 2017
imac pro that i'm using right now so the
idea that apple would release a new imac
pro with a 32 core m1 max gpu that's
basically only as powerful as a 5 year
old base model imac pro sounds
ridiculous so i thought they would
absolutely need to give the new model an
m1 max duo chip with a 64 core gpu and
then perhaps the weirdest part of all is
that the current 27 inch intel imac has
two chip options that are actually
faster than the m1 max chip in terms of
raw cpu performance and keep in mind
that these are 14 nanometer desktop
chips from 2020 and if we take a look at
intel's new alder lake chips even the
new i5 12600k is about 23 faster in
terms of single core and 39 faster in
terms of multi-core performance in
cinebench r23 and then the flagship i9
12 900 k which uses over four times more
power is actually 119
faster in terms of cinebench so with
that said i again assumed that apple
needs to pack in a 20 core m1 max duo
chip to compete but unfortunately mark
german just released a new report over
the weekend that hints at the most
disappointing imac pro we could ever
imagine apparently he believes that the
larger imac pro will come with m1 pro
and m1 max chip options that's it he
even confirmed this further by saying
this and with the m1 pro and m1 max
chips already on the market i don't
believe the imac pro launch is too
distant either while we'll get new max
in march i'm told apple is already
gearing up for another round of mac
releases around may or june and that's
exactly when ross young is personally
expecting apple to reveal the new imac
pro so this claim by mark german could
come as an absolute shock because many
of us were expecting a much more
powerful chip coming in the apple
silicon imac pro especially if apple
wants to give it the pro title and we
even had some reports from dylan dkt
that apple is working on a 12 chord [ __ ]
for the imac pro instead but mark still
believes that we'll only be getting up
to the m1 max so with all of that
disappointing news out of the way let's
actually try to make sense of the idea
of the imac pro not getting anything
more than an m1 max chip the first point
to make is that even though the raw
performance numbers for the m1 max look
disappointing compared to the
competition the real world performance
is actually really good for example the
affinity photo benchmark which was
optimized for apple silicon shows the 32
core m1 max as being the fastest gpu in
the world for that editing app even
beating out high-end desktop gpus and in
terms of video editing performance the
m1 max outperformed our 15 000 mac pro
in various tests even the ones we didn't
think it could pull ahead in like 8k
canon raw and for things like
programming we were surprised to see
that the m1 max was quite a bit faster
than the mac pro
so even though the raw performance
numbers aren't that impressive the real
world performance is actually more than
enough for most people out there so that
right there could be a good reason for
apple not to bother with putting an m1
max duo into the imac pro since the
regular m1 max is already enough for
almost everyone out there and to make
this point very clear max's friend owns
a full-time wedding videography business
with multiple employees and they all use
m1 max no not the new m1 max macbooks
but literally 24 inch m1 imacs and he
himself ended up replacing his trashcan
2013 mac pro with an m1 macbook air
instead of getting a desktop 2019 mac
pro and he's never been happier in fact
he was initially planning on using the
m1 macbook air until the new 16-inch m1
max macbook pro was released but he's
been so happy with his macbook air that
he decided to keep it since it's fast
enough for all of his video editing
needs so the point that i'm making is
that real people and real businesses are
using apple's original m1 chip with
great success and that's not even the m1
max chip which is many times faster
especially for high-end workflows so in
reality most people out there probably
do not need anything more than the m1
max chip and they definitely don't need
the crazy 20 core m1 max duo chip and i
think a lot of us have fallen under
benchmark sickness with many of us
wanting our machines to be the fastest
in terms of benchmarks for bragging
rights even if it ends up being absolute
overkill for the tasks that we actually
need it for so while i would really
really like apple to pack in an m1 max
duo chip into the imac pro i have to
admit that for my workflow of using
photoshop in final cut pro for editing
the regular 10 core m1 max chip in the
16 inch macbook pro is probably already
overkill for my needs and going even
further if apple gave the imac pro an m1
max duo it would likely be so fast that
it would cannibalize the sales of their
upcoming high-end mac pro desktop
machine since that 20 core duo chip
would literally be fast enough for 95
of the common use cases out there so
what apple could do is limit the imac
pro to just the m1 max chip perhaps
upping the clock speeds a bit to make it
a bit more powerful and then offer
people who actually need much more power
the high-end mac pro desktop machine and
the major benefit to this is that it
would allow them to lower the base price
of the imac pro to make it more
affordable to the average consumer
likely around two thousand dollars at
the base price instead of the previous
imac pro which started at a massive five
thousand dollars and then on top of that
i already concluded in a different video
that the m1 max duo chip wouldn't be
able to fit within the imac pro's chin
but if the best option is the regular m1
max chip then they can easily fit it
within the chin and keep the design as
thin as they'd like to make it without
having to go all out on the cooling and
just like mark german said earlier doing
this would allow them to get this new
imac pro out earlier without having to
wait for this new duo chip or anything
like that so in the grand scheme of
things the reality is that apple could
easily get away with releasing an m1 pro
and m1 max imac pro and people would
still be buying it left and right
including ourselves but hopefully mark
german is wrong about all of this and
hopefully we actually do get a more
powerful chat and with that said let me
know what you think down in the comment
section below about all of these leaks
and rumors and if you enjoyed this video
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and check out one of those two right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]